[Music]
today's recipes are big on spices herbs
and wonderful aromatics
I've taken my inspiration all the way
from the Arabian Peninsula to Turkey and
North Africa and put together a
fantastic Middle Eastern breakfast lunch
and dinner I absolutely love dishes from
this part of the world so for my
ultimate Middle Eastern food expect lots
of incredible grilled meats and
vegetables with pulses and delicious
fresh and zingy flavors first up for
breakfast a staple in Middle Eastern
food filo pastry and I'm making crispy
and fragrant triangles with luxurious
honey yogurt
next it's lunch and my take on a Turkish
classic Lamb koftas with yogurt and mint
and a vibrant beetroot and chickpea
hummus
delicious
for dinner I dragged my eldest daughter
away from her school books for a lesson
in the kitchen and some father-daughter
time I've got revision to be doing don't
worry this
[Applause]
we're cooking up a taste of Arabian
Nights with quail in pomegranate
molasses a bright butter bean salad
followed by one of the Region's most
loved exports sweet and sticky but clava
wow it smells so good these are my
ultimate Middle Eastern dishes breakfast
lunch and dinner first up it's breakfast
and my incredibly easy fragrant crispy
filo delicious with a simple honey
yogurt
now
these are beautiful
pastry sheets now it is possible to make
it
but to be honest to try and stretch
the pastry that thin and get it even
it's an absolute nightmare Life's too
short to make it at home when you can
buy amazing filo pastry
so
when working with it always get a nice
damp cloth
and just lay
the damp cloth over it that keeps it
nice and moist and it stops
the filler pastry from actually drying
out put a pan on to melt your butter
it's the butter that gives the
crispiness
to the filo pastry
if you're ever going to brush or coat
feel a pastry with butter and make sure
that butter is nicely seasoned
you take
your first layer layer onto the balls
nice brush that with your butter
and the nice thing about filo pastry is
that it can be used for Savory and sweet
these are going to have a fragrance
Savory flavor with thyme black pepper
and parmesan cheese so no need for salt
lift up the corner
unfold very quickly brush the ends
and just
nip
those ends together
non-stick pan on a little splash of
olive oil frying the pastry for one to
two minutes on each side
so you want them to sort of puff up the
secrets keep them quickly you can smell
that cheese in that time you're looking
for them to become golden and crispy
simple as that and then out
smells delicious
and as they sit and cool down instantly
they become really nice and crispy
the filo goes fantastically well with
thick creamy Greek yogurt and a drizzle
of runny honey
there's something quite sort of Middle
East and about the herbs the yogurt and
the honey and the sort of crispy
textures
of the filo pastry an alternative Savory
breakfast
when you want a stunning and
sophisticated breakfast that mixes
fragrant herbs and cheese with glorious
honey yogurt this Middle Eastern treat
hits the spot and it's so simple to make
[Music]
the more you learn about ingredients the
better and the more varied your cooking
will become
[Music]
a closer look at some I'm using today
first up I've already used filo pastry
in my breakfast and I'm using it later
for a sweet dessert
made from just flour water salt and oil
that's incredibly fiddly to roll into
tissue thin sheets
so I like to use good shop bought
ready-made filo which makes cooking
Middle East and Delicacies like the
lemon baklava I'm making later a breeze
thank you
Quail may seem quintessentially British
but this little game bird originates in
the Middle East
it's got a lovely light gamey flavor and
it's quick and easy to cook in the
Middle East it's eaten whole or
flattened and grilled over charcoal
I'm marinating mine in pomegranate
molasses and roasted it it's the magic
of the east on a plate
[Music]
these are a staple in Middle Eastern
cooking
chickpeas either come as flour dried or
ready to go in cans or jars
[Music]
cooking the dried ones from scratch
don't add salt into the finished cooking
you can also buy them pre-cooked in
either brine or spring water
they're packed with protein and so
versatile whether as a stuffing in a
salad or Blended as part of the beetroot
hummus I'm making next
one of the brilliant things about
cooking at home is being able to bring
ingredients and influences from all over
the world right into your very own
kitchen for my ultimate Middle Eastern
lunch I'm bringing a touch of
Mediterranean Sunshine into my home in a
Grace guide London gorgeous grilled lamb
copters with my incredible Twist on a
middle eastern classic hummus
first job glorious beetroot hummus
I'm going to blend and puree the cooked
chickpea and the beetroot now the
beetroot gives that pickly delicious
flavor to the hummus beetroots in
with the chickpea
a nice seasoning of salt and pepper
a tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
of tahini this is roasted sesame seeds
pounded and mixed with oil
now crushed garlic and toasted cumin
seeds grind then pop into a blender
[Music]
I love that nice dark Rich color and you
finish it with a nice
lemon
slice it in half
take out the seeds and squeeze the fresh
lemon juice at the end just wakes up the
acidity in the beetroot but really cuts
the richness of the chickpea and the
lemon juice is pivotal it really brings
the beetroot and the chickpeas together
chickpeas are packed with protein very
dense and it needs that kind of acidity
one more little blend
lovely
nice little taste
that's delicious homemade beetroot
hummus so tasty and it really is that
easy to make to finish some toasted
cumin seeds and sumac
now this is delicious it's a sort of
Middle Eastern spice
and then
some sesame seeds finish that off
with margarine almost done now for my
koftas onion
nice and finely diced
garlic three nice clothes
squeeze the garlic
over the onions onions
garlic in
you get a really nice color on them
after that
a nice teaspoon of chili flakes
now into our pestle and mortar with a
teaspoon of toasted cumin give that
little just salt in there helps grind it
down that is such a lovely smell
aromatic
exciting spicy intriguing
once ground to a fine powder sprinkle
your spices into the onion and garlic to
create a wonderful aromatic paste now
for the lamb mints
lightly season it
and then add all that wonderful flavor
next for some freshness parsley and mint
roughly chopped and a lug of olive oil
put your hands in there
and give that a really good mix
traditionally you can see
koftas on little sticks barbecue skewers
and depending Where You Are
they have different sort of variations
and shapes and sizes I much prefer the
nice little sort of
almost like little mini
Burgers like little mini sliders
but these can be griddled
these can be fried in a pan or even
cooked on the barbecue
start by Rolling the mix into a golf
ball size then flatten out always
lightly oil
your plate
that way when you set them in the fridge
don't need to be old again they're just
going straight into the pan because
they've got oil underneath and all on
top keep your hands lightly oiled
and it helps to stop the lamb from
sticking to your fingers then pop them
into the fridge to set and firm up
before cooking
now you can cook the copter in a frying
pan on the barbecue or an amazing little
griddle pan
get the plaque really nice and hot
whilst that heats I'm making a yogurt
dip I love a nice sort of fresh minted
yogurt
put fresh mint leaves
salt and a pinch of toasted cumin and
black pepper into a pestle and mortar to
grind as you start to sort of blend
the mint almost turns into a nice fresh
mint puree
and smell out of that
is incredible
add yogurt and I like Greek best and a
squeeze of lemon
but look at that now
beautiful now for the coffee so they go
on
[Music]
one of the biggest problems on cooking
Costco is that they move them too early
and they start to break up but let them
Grill and by grilling them they'll
naturally lift off the bar once they're
charcoaled and so literally two two and
a half minutes each side
now
turn it over
beautiful
smell is incredible
once browned on both sides they're ready
to serve
on
[Music]
delicious I absolutely love lunches like
this because it's sort of bold food
that's packed full of freshness and
great flavors these quick and easy minty
lamb koftas serve with beetroot hummus
are perfect for a relaxed meal your
family and friends will all want to tuck
into
one of the things I love about Middle
Eastern food is its vibrancy it really
creates a great atmosphere in your
kitchen with lots of color lots of fresh
herbs fruit vegetables nuts honey and
sweet syrups and for my ultimate Middle
Eastern dinner I'm filling the house
with the Fantastic smells of aromatic
cooked meats
[Music]
helping me in the kitchen to take a
wetland break from my studies is my
eldest daughter Megan
first job at pomegranate marinade for
the quail which have been cut in half
and flattened
aren't they small yeah it's tiny so it's
almost like a sort of nice entrance into
eating something slightly gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt and pepper and all spatchcock
means is that the rib cage has been
taken out and they're fattened down and
because the bird is so delicate it's
flattened to cook evenly and it really
is a nice sort of light gamey dense
chicken flavor
so I've got toast the spices when you
think of Middle Eastern food it's packed
with amazing flavors tablespoon of
coriander
a teaspoon of cumin
and a nice little seasoning and salt so
we toast them now intensifying the
flavor and they start smoking lightly
that's a nice indication that they're
ready
grind away so the best thing then I'm
not gonna send it close today thank you
this hand here keeps it nice and firm
and you grind that into a nice powder
for belly please
doesn't it yeah so to get that in really
go around the outside and that grinds it
up
I'll go around and pass some water
more times than you've kissed boys
squeeze the garlic in next
little glug a volleyball okay and then I
want you to pour six tablespoons please
so that is pomegranate molasses so it's
like an aged bathroom with vinegar but
really reduced down give that a nice mix
up
very sweet dad a little taste
sweet but sour yeah it is so good though
no
take a nice spoon
put it inside the quail you can even do
this
the night before because if you pop them
in the fridge let the quail marinate
anywhere from half an hour to overnight
[Music]
ultimate Middle Eastern dessert it's got
to be baklava
start by melting butter in a pan
chopped pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combined with caster sugar and
lemon zest
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray
Place half a sheet of FILA pastry on the
base
brush well with melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix
repeat and press down between layers
you're looking to create 30 to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut The Baklava into bite-sized
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30 to 40 minutes
meanwhile make your delicious citrusy
syrup simply add water to a pan along
with caster sugar
and the zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar has fully dissolved now
to get the baklav a wonderful sweetness
removed from the oven and whilst hot
pour over the syrup so each layer is
gloriously sticky leave The Baklava to
absorb the syrup for at least 12 hours
these delicious sticky treats will keep
for a week but they're so Moorish
they'll be gone in a Flash
foreign
[Music]
pick up your quail
and skin side down first okay
get all that nice color
and always open them up as well in the
pan
okay we'll get that skin crisp crispy
that's right
smell that pomegranate
and really smell it smells so good you
get all that marinade in there you know
cook with it as well don't waste it how
long on average does it take to cook
this three 12 to 15 minutes in the oven
a little touch of water
in
[Music]
bring that up to the boil
in the oven 180 so 12 to 15 minutes
[Applause]
okay yeah
the final job before serving a Herby
butter bean salad to go with my quail in
pomegranate molasses
now one of the things that I love about
Middle East and salads is the sort of
crunch and the color as well butter
beans
it's gonna be the base of our salad from
there little radishes
and sort of top
and tell them get them like that
and throw them in there's nothing small
and dainty in there okay so with the
spring onions
nice we're gonna use the greens and the
whites I want to slice
along that way this time it's got those
nice light shards okay yeah
now the croutons are made out of these
little Pita breads just slice lengthways
and salad oh yes
so this salad is all about texture so
cucumber okay
and take out the seeds
how come you're taking the seeds out it
just makes the salad
very watery
shower okay cucumber juice delicious
like this you go yeah you got me going
you really got me going no no no no oh
yeah I thought revision to be doing
don't worry this is far more important
trust me who needs exams where you can
cook for a living you gave me the mic
down it's fine it's fine it's fine be a
chef for a living have a proper job
don't talk your things out like that
you'll be thumbless let's go now good
cucumber in from there
take your nice
vibrant Tomatoes it's nice down
resembles that that's right and with the
celery
so we need some mint and parsley
I want you sprinkling it in there and
really mix it through the herbs give it
that nice kind of freshness
but I want a bit of a bite in there now
I love pomegranate so just carefully
poking that up you can then just drop
them on top so we've got a bit of
fruitiness now into the salad
for crunch simply cut up whole Pita
breads fry in a really hot pan with
olive oil into a wonderfully golden
crispy and irresistible
out
into a
sieve
okay
next a Sprinkle of sumac
that's a dried fruit from the Middle
East the zest of a lemon and the juice
then a drizzle of olive oil
and last but not least my crunchy Pitter
croutons
they do croutons on well they've gotten
hard can you just lift that up I'm
mixing your hands there nice and jump
just a few fingertips there you go so we
just mix there you go
you don't crush anything it doesn't
crush anything but then let's just take
a little bean
wow is that delicious nice now Quail
it's got that Rudy
mmm sort of toasted almost like a sort
of light smells so good barbecue flavor
can't wait to try it
[Music]
it just lines everything up a little bit
and it goes so well with the pomegranate
now just
wow that'll smell better than any
boyfriend you'll ever have oh God
beg to differ
okay good let's go
how delicious is that that's so
delicious
my middle eastern Feast of quail with a
pomegranate molasses and butter bean
salad with baklava to follow when dishes
are this aromatic and colorful there's
no wonder that Middle Eastern food is
always a hit
right
look at this do I just saw the seller oh
wow
till how's the quail
it's really good thank you I love it
how's the salad it's really nice
delicious
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
was it easy to make yeah it was actually
very simple and fun
[Music]
you're gonna get it tonight
okay today it's all about clean fresh
zingy flavors and speed a few years ago
I traveled around Cambodia Thailand
Vietnam and Malaysia learning all I
could from the chefs over there and I
really fell in love with all their food
I brought back those influences to my
home kitchen and I've been incorporating
them into my cooking ever since so get
ready for some cracking recipes here on
my ultimate Southeast Asian dishes
if you want a pick-me-up first thing in
the morning forget a double espresso I
think chili gives you an even bigger
boost and it's incredible in my
breakfast fruit salad
for lunch it's my take on a traditional
noodle soup with fresh clams for dessert
banana fritters bursting with flavor and
one of the best things about Southeast
Asian food is it's easy and a great way
to get your kids cooking Jack to prove
it my son Jack's joining me in the
kitchen to cook up some sticky spicy
chicken wings because it's your favorite
so with fragrant Thai rice and stir-fry
green beans with soy and peanut dressing
this is my ultimate Southeast Asian food
breakfast lunch and dinner
right one of my favorites it's a Tang
fruit salad and it's for breakfast would
you believe start off with a chili now
give it a little rub
so
you can hear those seeds being released
get your knife
and come all the way down
turn it over and just slice it
into four and then
finely chop that chili
I want this salad slightly hot
so I'm going to use all the chili but
half the seeds the seeds are where the
heat is so the less you use the milder
your dish nicely chopped
next
one of my favorite Pace Tamarind paste
this is quiet tart quite sour but it's a
wonderful compliment to the sweetness of
the fruit and it goes brilliantly well
with a Chili Palmer sugar
and this is where it sweetens up
the dressing because it enriches it then
the zest and the juice of a lime cut it
into quarters
and then twist the lime so you maximize
all that juice out now to finish that
dressing off some toasted peanuts
pan nice and hot
a little touch of salt
that'll help dry roast the peanuts even
quicker
make sure you get really nice dark color
on those peanuts because it will really
transform that dressing
crush your roasted nuts the mess free
way simply wrap them in a clean cloth
and use a rolling pin or a pan to bash
them
Crush
that's the hard bit done
now for the fruit and here's an easy way
to prep a pineapple pineapple take off
the top
take off the bottom
and stand it up use a cornery knife
and follow down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
there
the secret behind doing it this way is
not losing half the pineapple there's
nothing wrong with a few Brown bits it's
all good fiber
slice the pineapple in half
and then slice down
each quarter slice across and chop
delicious
pineapple chunks
next apples and pears diced then to give
a lovely fresh Light note the seeded
cucumber I don't want the seeds in the
fruit salad the cucumber seeds will make
it very watery and
dilute the strength for that wonderful
chili in there cucumber in with some
sweetness
delicious mango this slice it nicely
that you're dressing and just drizzle
that over the fruit salad in
The Secret of a good fruit salad
is not drowning in the dressing but
really make sure that you've got that
nice coating on all the fruits
don't worry about just having for
breakfast because this is the kind of
Tangy fruit salad you can have for lunch
a healthy snack in the afternoon but it
transforms a traditional fruit salad
into something really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kick of chili
trust me it's an incredible breakfast
and a guaranteed pick me up in the
morning
[Music]
next I'm showing you a sensational
Southeast Asian lunch and dinner
here's a closer look at some of the key
ingredients you'll need to buy to make
them
first up a Southeast Asian essential
lemongrass buy it as a paste dried or
powdered but I love it fresh best
most of the flavor is in the thick Bowl
band which can be either crushed or
chopped to add flavor to a dish wrapped
in klingfill it will keep up to 10 days
in the fridge
lemongrass is Central to Southeast Asian
Foods especially Thai and I'm using it
in my lunch and dinner recipes
[Music]
another Southeast Asian staple is
tamarind made from the fruit from The
Tamarind Tree biting powder cake or
paste form
sweet and sour at the same time and
gives Brown sauces and Worcestershire
sauce their distinct flavors
I've already used it in my fruit salad
now I'm going to put it in my chicken
marinade for dinner too
[Applause]
lastly is clams
their prize from all over southeast Asia
but the most common types to buy in
Britain are beautiful plump Venus clams
sweet tasty middle of the clams and
razor clams which are shaped like an
old-fashioned Cutthroat razor
clams are fantastic raw bait in sauces
or in soups like this one I'm making for
lunch
there's one rule only prepare live ones
so discard any that don't open during
cooking
[Applause]
[Music]
all over southeast Asia you find people
cooking and eating the huge bowls of
delicious noodle soups it's a very
simple dish but the variations you get
are extraordinary different Meats
different fish and even different
dumplings but what I love most about
noodle soup is the fact that it's a
complete Meal carbs protein and
vegetables in one big bowl of happiness
for my ultimate Southeast Asian lunch
I'm showing you one of my favorites
spicy clamor noodle soup followed by
sweet Moorish banana and coconut
fritters for dessert
first up my dessert banana fritters
take your bananas
and to get them really nice and soft
just rub
banana sip together flour and baking
powder
sugar into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially with the
fritters mix the batter nice and crisp
start crushing
and use the back
of the fork and just push it against the
side of the bowl
and then
once you mix that through
I'm gonna make that mix now slightly
fragrant with some lime zest
now
the lime just really elevates the sort
of richness and the denseness of the
banana
cover with slim fill so it doesn't get a
skin on top sit that in the fridge for
15 minutes
as the banana Fritter mixture rests I'm
getting on with my broth for the noodle
and clam soup
fish sauce is the base
bring that up to the boil now to take
that broth to another level
in with chopped shallots fresh ginger
and a whole chili seeds and all I
actually quite like it spicy
just
chop once and into the broth
bring up the ball and let it simmer
Gallagher it's a sort of
almost like a softer version of Ginger
slightly Milder
you can use galangal paste but I prefer
the fresh stuff the stems
for coriander we'll finish it off with
the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
Southeast Asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves
for me
one of my favorites incredibly pungent
Strong full of flavor very acidic but
gives a really nice Aroma to the broth
just tear them
and
now the lemongrass
so the secret here that's where all the
flavor is right at the very end so you
take the back of the knife and you just
bash the lemongrass
it's all that flavor is going to run out
in seconds that's the base
of the broth down and the longer you
leave it the more intense it gets whilst
the broth infuses soak your rice noodles
in boiling water for 10 minutes just
enough time to fry your fritters the
batter now is ready
use a metal spoon to drop the batter up
to the bottom of the pan
and then they hit that oil they puff up
that's why it's important to put your
spoon into the oil so the mixture runs
off
creates this lovely little fritter
and then gently
fry get a slotted spoon a nice and
carefully turn them over
smell of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes
as they start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked
off with a gas
and just let them drained are those
Beauties lovely
sprinkling when they're hot with sugar
actually sticks them
they're done ready to go the last job
before serving the clams never be scared
of cooking shellfish the most important
rule is if they are slightly opened a
millimeter discard it make sure mussels
clams are always tight cook the clams
for just three to five minutes or until
they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch up
fish sauce a little sprinkle of sugar
drain your noodles
into the bowl
the addy texture some delicious bean
sprouts
get your lime fresh squeeze and lime
juice in beautiful
literally as the stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically
so they cook beautifully
the flavor from inside the clam has
enhanced the broth
smell is incredible
the clams cooked finished with fresh
coriander and serve
there you have perfect lunch
a delicious spicy clam noodle
with an amazing banana fritter
quite spicy clam noodle soup and banana
and coconut fritters made in minutes and
proof you only need to travel as far as
your kitchen to get the taste of
Southeast Asia
[Music]
when I was traveling in Southeast Asia
one of the things that really struck me
was how seriously they take meal times
family and friends all sit down together
to eat catch up and have a great time
it's a really big part of their daily
life so how it works is they put a whole
load of different dishes in the middle
of the table and everyone else
themselves I love this way of eating
it's very social and really relaxed so
I've adopted it here in our house too
I also like the family to share the
cooking
today my son Jack's joining me in the
kitchen he's got a vested interest in
learning to cook sticky spiced chicken
wings
Jack
give us a hand please Bob why
because it's your favorites yeah chicken
wings okay all right let's start off
with the marinade Tamarind paste in
first
all that into there
all of that yeah all of that okay
yep in so two tablespoons of palm sugar
please
heated sugar
um it's a really good question it's a
natural palm sugar and it's perfect for
marinades how many wings you think
you've eaten so far at the age of 13. oh
I eat probably 50 a year 50 a year yeah
something like that a nice sprinkle of
chili flakes depends how hot you like
them oh I love them hot hot uh don't
forget the girls you know they start
complaining when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food so
I know
so in there we've got palm sugar
Tamarind paste chili flakes some garlic
one nice tablespoon
or fish sauce please check which is
looking really good isn't it and then
I've got a tablespoons of oil for
marinade
in
a nice little taste
not your finger jack
ET
that's really good right Wings in get
your hands in there and start rubbing in
the marinade please okay so the secret
now is to coat
the chicken wings and all that marinade
yeah yeah
how long do you leave them in here do
you want the longer the better
cover that
when Clinton
excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
all right so they've marinated now if
you take the tray out people
bottom one thank you and then we're
gonna put some tin foil on there thank
you
so
that in half
let's stop something sticking and
that'll stop
the wings from burning so from there get
them really dipped in that marinade and
try and get the wing like that and just
sort of scoop it
no not there to get that really nice
glaze on there
and then just
yeah
it's all like garlic or roast
and then we've got all those wings
beautifully
done I can make them ready for the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes yep good man
accent
nice it's hot wings are in
right
to go with my ultimate Southeast Asian
dinner rice cooked in homemade Thai
green curry paste for the easy green
curry paste roughly chopped coriander
lemongrass
green chilies
Lime Leaf shallots
garlic and ginger
[Music]
a lug of oil and Blitz
the pace takes minutes to make but it'll
keep for up to 10 days if covered with
oil and stored in a sealed jar in the
fridge
to awaken the flavors lime roll to
release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
heat the paste until aromatic
add in cool or leftover rice I love
using fragrant jasmine rice but your
standard long grain rice is great too
when thoroughly heated through serve
Thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this it's
incredible but simply add to chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes right now for the green beans
beans in
bring the water up the ball what's the
first thing I should put in there beans
so nice pinch of salt in there yeah so
make an amazing dressing two nice
tablespoons yep a bit crunchy peanut
butter please why is it crunchy I'll
give it texture
and it'll be nice and sort of chunky
green beans in okay got the rice the
green beans
we're gonna blast them for two two and a
half minutes what does blanching
actually mean blanching means sort of
Park cooking okay I'm gonna blanch them
in boiling water and then finish them in
the pan use the back of the spoon will
be a little bit easier
teaspoon of brown sugar and she goes
nice
is that a little bit too thick maybe
yeah it is let's put a little touch more
soy sauce in there let it down
yeah yeah much better nice
I'm gonna get a pan on now for my beans
so a little taste do you taste there
it's so good oh man
hmm wow so have you got the garlic right
there and just slice the garlic down
like this
just keep the knife nice and flat that
way you'll slice through it
'll take your time don't worry about the
speed I'm technically right first just
cut it in half okay
okay your fingers good and then lay the
flat side down so it's nice and sturdy
and that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good I'll drain the beans
nice A little tablespoon of oil
put the pan nice and hot
for the garlic and paper
okay
nice
smell that already
so give that a little toss so when you
toss it push it down
push away and pull back
okay have a little go
push it down and gently that's it take
your time
nice
so push down
and pull back up that's it nice so it's
getting nice and golden brown green
beans are drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans
okay with the rice
and this one of that
oh wow I want you now spoon the dressing
with these here she goes nice
how delicious does that look
what's Daddy's policy at home no waste
no waste no waste bud
now
smell that now
oh wow it doesn't smell like green beans
oh thanks
how nice is that
a little bit amazing right
that's the rice that's the green beans
[Music]
no I want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please
nice and generous for the sesame seed
I'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now
all that's left for your favorites to
come out
don't those beans smell amazing yeah
Jack look at those Beauties one for me
one for you three for me one for you
and I like it to sprinkle some spring
onions
on top please
nice and generous you're transformed are
very cheap and cheersful chicken wing
yeah right and take them over please do
not drop them okay Jack let's go nice
this is my ultimate simple Southeast
Asian dinner sticky spicy chicken wings
Thai green curry rice and fantastic
beans with chili peanut dressing
guaranteed to get the fussies of eaters
into greens
Holly Tana ready for Jack's wings I was
trying to help himself and pass them
along chat with some mice
I know you're allergic to anything green
how are the beans
I've seen you eat more green beans the
last five minutes they have them the
last 10 years
now I know the secret you have to put
peanut butter on it are you going to dig
into those chicken wings now fingers
right definitely
oh wow nice very very good very nice
Jack yeah they're tasty right there's no
dainty way of doing this no Holly don't
worry about your nail varnish you'll be
fine oh
you're such a lady
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck